hola soy lunar de khan academy khan
academy se creó basado en un nuevo
sistema que acelera el progreso del
estudiante y lo ayuda a aprender lo
llamamos dominio porque asegura que un
alumno haya entendido completamente un
concepto o lo haya entendido a la
perfección antes de pasar al siguiente
como maestro puedes asignar una meta de
dominio a un alumno oa toda la clase
para asegurar que tienen los fundamentos
necesarios y los conocimientos para
pasar al siguiente nivel este vídeo es
un repaso de cómo usar dominio de khan
academy en tu salón de clases primero
veremos cómo asignar dominio a un curso
selecciona una clase en la pestaña
contenido verás un botón para asignar
una meta de dominio para cada uno de los
cursos con ejercicios para todo el año
actualmente ofrecemos dominio para todos
los cursos de contenido completo que son
la mayoría de nuestros cursos de
matemáticas física y química cuando
asignas una meta de dominio rectas a que
tu alumno domine todo el curso
selecciona una clase un alumno en
particular
luego escoge una fecha límite recuerda
que a tus alumnos les puede tomar varios
meses dominar un curso completo ahora
revisaremos la experiencia de los
alumnos cada alumno podrá ver su meta de
dominio en la parte superior de su
página en la pestaña tarea el alumno
puede consultarlo en cualquier momento y
seguir adelante hasta alcanzar su meta
también puede seguir trabajando desde
las aplicaciones ios y android cómo
funciona el sistema dominio de khan
academy cada habilidad o concepto tiene
varios niveles y los alumnos pueden
ganar puntos adicionales con cada nivel
nuevo los alumnos pueden practicar de
varias formas pueden trabajar un solo
concepto en un ejercicio o pueden
practicar varios conceptos en una prueba
examen de unidad o reto del curso
mientras más respuestas correctas tengan
los alumnos ascienden desde un nivel ha
familiarizado a competente y el último
nivel es dominado para que los alumnos
puedan llegar a dominado primero deben
pasar por competente y luego demostrar
sus conocimientos en una prueba de
unidad o reto del curso cuando un alumno
tiene problemas con una
a nivel de dominio baja y aparece un
símbolo al lado del concepto para
ayudarlo a recordar en donde se debe
enfocar más si un alumno se equivoca
repetidas veces en un problema pasará al
nivel con dificultad y aparecerá un
punto rojo junto a este concepto
dominará un concepto individual permite
avanzar en la unidad y en todo el curso
los alumnos siempre pueden ver hasta qué
punto han llegado y que deben ejercitar
próximamente las pruebas y exámenes
podrán incluir preguntas de repaso en
espiral de conceptos que los alumnos
hayan practicado anteriormente en otras
unidades del mismo curso ayudando así a
que los alumnos retengan más información
ahora revisemos los reportes para
maestros regresamos al panel de tutor en
una clase la pestaña progreso te
mostrará el avance de los alumnos hacia
dominar un curso en específico
primero verás el progreso de un alumno
en el dominio del curso y también verás
el promedio de dominio de todo el grupo
a continuación verás el nivel de dominio
de cada unidad individual digamos que
estás empezando el año y te quieres
enfocar en la primera unidad selecciona
una unidad y podrás ver los detalles
adicionales incluyendo el nivel de
dominio de cada concepto individual
si notas que varios alumnos tienen
problemas con una habilidad puedes
asignar ejercicios adicionales en la
pestaña progreso hablaremos más sobre
cómo crear asignaturas en otro vídeo
algunos consejos para los maestros
dominar el curso puede sentirse como una
tarea gigantesca lo que recomendamos es
que lo divides en pequeñas metas
mensuales también puedes considerar a
dejar que tus alumnos se enfoquen en una
unidad específica durante todo el año y
luego revisar los reportes de unidad
para ver su progreso no tienes que
asignar la misma meta de dominio a todos
los alumnos para diferenciarlos puedes
asignarles a los alumnos diferentes
cursos algunos maestros asignan una meta
de dominio de un curso anterior como
repaso al principio del año para más
información visita khan academy punto o
hereje diagonal visual ces